[Musique]
quelle équipe nationale spialo va-t-il
choisir la France ou le Sénégal j'ai
hâte de le voir en équipe nationale et
s'il a envie de porter le maillot bleu
oui il a envie de jouer pour le pays de
son papa quand est-ce que vous allez
clarifier votre situation en ce moment
tu es dans l' sauce tu dis pas qu'on a
choisi la France tu gardes l'exclu pour
demain soir je compte sur toi Osman le
Sénégal coûte dans No ven la fierté du
pays de tes ancêtres fils pourquoi tu
dois choisir ENF tes français et
sénégalais c'est absurde non je crois
que si Zidan avait joué pour l'Algérie
serait devenu Zizou on peut pas c'est la
règle bah écoute m con cette règle
tu vas pas faire le trait B arteain il
aura la presse ce soir il y aura la
presse oui sera là leur boulot ça peut
te le boulot tu as vu ta
gueule pe importe le choix que tu fais
il sera interprété comme une prise de
position politique ma seule position
c'est numéro
10 t'inquiète laisse-moi faire frérot je
vais gérer dou doucement doucement
quelle soirée de
merde quoi je pass